je vous ai mis la rose la composition de
la cagette avec la provenance est une
idée recette pour cette semaine m
12 références de fruits et légumes par
cagettes 5 kg qui sont directement
livrés à domicile
mareva est l'une des clients de la cage
est solidaire une toute jeune entreprise
je suis pour acheter mes fruits et
légumes chez des commerçants plutôt
qu'en grande surface
parce que nos nouveaux goûts ça change
totalement et surtout en ce moment faut
faut soutenir les commerces la cage est
solidaire est le fruit d'une fusion
temporaire celle de deux entreprises
bucs oise elle est née sept
hélas cette vision depuis deux semaines
raf koussa a délaissé le caramel pour
devenir livreur on s'approvisionne
majoritairement chez des producteurs
locaux et dans un souci diversité où
nous on va chercher nos produits
ailleurs en france et certains produits
à l'étranger comme l'ananas ou ou les
haricots verts en ce moment on a l'amour
des bons produits du bien manger et on a
le holà les équipements on a le matériel
on a nos camions on a une chambre froide
qui nous sert déjà une initiative qu'ils
espèrent poursuivre avec des
compositions personnalisées la cagette a
livré 150 clients depuis son lancement